i've set up ten different cameras across
the spectrum from the iphone
through the dv cameras we've got a gopro
the canon dslrs sony mirrorless cameras
we've got the sony f55 the alexa mini
and the red dragon
to give you the most thorough
comprehensive full-on
practical premiere downright dope
camera test
what's up the devil watch up the
badminton watch out for the fingerlings
[ __ ] with your magic
don't watch out for me though i promise
i'm your friend i won't eat you i love
you
i just want to hug you
[Music]
in this month's episode of creator
camera hacks ever made on youtube or
anywhere else ever because that's how we
do it here so if you're into learning
new [ __ ]
pretty pictures and good stories then
click the subscribe button below
i'm dan meis your collaborator and
internet friend so
let's dive into everything camera
cameras are everywhere there's one
facing you while you watch this unless
you cover it up like me
if you're on your laptop there's one
your phone there's two
one you never use on your tablet but
it's there they're on street corners
shop
ceilings office walls doorbells
dashboards and bumpers
i think it's safe to say more video
content is being captured and shared at
a rate we can't even conceive
now more than ever and most of the
cameras we have the ability to control
we know little to nothing about so we
just switch them on auto and shoot away
hoping for the right moment that's going
to captivate an audience
or you're a filmmaker that's learning
the ropes and just can't seem to crack
it the way you'd like to
i'm going to share everything there is
to know about camera along with many
useful hacks
to turn you from so-so to pro within 10
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
minutes
dope tracking i don't mean to boast but
my collaborator and good friend jason
and i made it
and where can you get these tracks that
i've made in my previous films like
seeing sounds
i'm glad you asked on the epidemic sound
library that's
where so click on the link below to sign
up and create your epidemic sound
account today to make sure that you're
ready for when we drop the albums on
there
and not just that epidemic sound is the
sponsor of these creator hacks videos
as they want to empower creators through
education which is the same thing that i
want to do so that's why they're
a collaborator and sponsor of mine so
big ups to them and thank you for the
support
but more on that later let's talk
cameras
firstly a camera doesn't actually work
like an eyeball does
there are many significant differences
where the only similarities between the
eye
and this incredible invention are that
they both use lenses to focus the light
and have sensors to capture it
photograph in greek photo meaning light
and graph meaning
to capture but both have completely
different ways of processing the image
for immediate viewing through what's
known as photoreceptors
in short you don't actually see with
your eyes rather your very active brain
that's filling in a lot of gaps and has
the unfortunate habit of being eluded in
low light
and with what's known as blind spots and
therefore i would argue that a camera is
a much more reliable source of capturing
what's
actually there what's happening in front
of
you uh but then you would actually still
need your eyeball to see that
it gets very confusing and we'll speak
about that another time a camera is
basically a light proof box built to
capture light the diaphragm of the
camera determines the amount of light
that's lit in
in the front of this are lenses light
bends when it travels through different
spaces through different mediums such as
from air to glass
the light is in focus to a central point
when you click the shutter button the
movable mirror shifts upward in the
camera the light stops when it reaches
the film in the camera which forms an
inverted singular image and a video
camera basically does this 24 times a
second the same speed a human eyeball
processes light
that's the stripped-down version of how
a basic 16-millimeter camera works but
the world of video cameras has evolved
beyond our imagination in the past 20
years
and we can now do so much more than the
human eye ever could there are so many
different capabilities that money can
buy you but expensive cameras don't buy
you skill
or finding nuance within your frame or
basically being able to
capture a creative shot therefore i've
added in many hacks within this video to
get you there with the cheaper cameras
too
i have 10 different cameras here from
the extremely basic mobile camera the
whole way up to the most high-end cinema
cameras
to showcase the similarities we're first
going to cover the fundamentals and then
we're going to get into the action of it
firstly we're going to look at exposure
then lighting then framing and last but
so far from least
camera movement the three keys to
exposure are your iso
which is the sensitivity of the camera's
sensor aperture which is the variable
opening by which light enters the camera
and shutter speed which is the nominal
time for which a shutter is open at any
given setting
achieving the correct exposure is a lot
like collecting rain in a bucket
while the rate of the rainfall is
uncontrollable three factors remain
under your control
the bucket's width the duration you
leave it in the rain
and the quantity of rain you want to
collect you just need to ensure you
don't collect
too little which will be underexposed
but that you also don't collect
too much overexposed there are many
combinations of how you expose your
image
you just need to understand the look you
are trying to achieve
first start by keeping your iso
reasonably low this will reduce the
amount of noise on your image
the shutter speed or shutter angle
should be double your frame rate to be
safe
and then let's look at your aperture
which controls how much light you let
into your camera
the more light the lower the number
known as your f-stop
the lower this number the shallower your
depth of field meaning that less is in
focus
this is great for portrait shots this
makes things look far more cinematic
to achieve this look on the cheap when
you have too much light to go shallow
you can make use of stockings to shoot
through this also helps with the
softness of your image as well as if you
want to take things further
attach a piece of glass to the front of
your lens to apply vaseline to it
leaving a small hole this gives you a
split die-off to feel then while we are
talking about ways to affect your image
to make it more cinematic
create a warm glow with a few
matchsticks as well as you can upcycle
your sandwich bag to create a soft glow
around your image
as well as if you have access to haze or
smoke machine this will create great
fractures of light
all these techniques can be used on all
cameras as demonstrated later
then the larger or f-stop number refers
to a deeper depth of field this is what
you want to do when shooting landscapes
and big wides
to rather get more in focus make sure
when shooting fast action
you up your shutter speed for a sharper
image then lastly change your iso
accordingly but generally don't push
this higher than 1
600 if you can even if you're shooting
on a camera like a sony that prides
itself on low light
it's not a good habit to get into
because when you move on to bigger
cameras
as you drift higher than 1000 iso you'll
start to notice the noise
it's super important you understand all
these three keys before you start
painting the rules to affect your image
i really enjoy shooting with a lower
shutter for intense running shots
where you feel the tension and the lag
on screen etc
it really all comes down to light and
using the light
firstly if you want a magic looking feel
to your image you should shoot in what's
known as magic
hour this isn't either dusk or dawn look
at this clip i took of gabby walking two
years ago on an iphone 8 camera
this natural look of shaky cell phone
footage does the shot more justice than
trying to affect it perfectly with
smooth camera movement and then grading
it because it would lose its
authenticity
i'm going to be doing a creator's hex
class on lighting entirely so i'm just
going to touch on
the knowledge you didn't yet know you
needed within the lighting sphere
okay understanding the bloody confusing
histogram a histogram is a graph showing
the distribution of light in an image
most cameras are capable of displaying a
histogram for each image stored on the
camera's memory card
look in your camera's settings to see if
you can display your histogram before
shooting a shot
your image is made up of millions of
pixels and every pixel has a value
representing its color the pixel's
brightness is derived from this value
a histogram shows you the number of
pixels of each brightness in your image
the scale along the bottom of the
histogram goes from left to right from
zero percent brightness which is black
or underexposed
to 100 brightness which is white the
taller the peak the more pixels of that
brightness are in the image
lens flares when used correctly lens
flares definitely make your image more
cinematic
if you're looking for jj abrams type
lens flares that run horizontally
through your frame you're gonna have to
fork out a lot of money to rent or
purchase what's known as anamorphic
lenses
please do not try any hacks here with
your spherical lenses to try and
get some sort of horizontal flare it
just looks terrible
rather make use of your spherical lens
and shoot during dawn or dusk
to get real flares coming into your
lanes in my opinion unless you're
shooting an action scene or fighting
scene a car commercial
normal spherical flares look just as
good if you don't have the luxury of
great light you can make use of a torch
or a cd as well as a few crystals to
give your frame very interesting
vignetting
shooting high speed means more light if
your camera has the ability to shoot 60
frames per second 120
or higher make sure you have sufficient
light remember that opening up your lens
to a low
f-stop is dangerous because there's more
time for your audience to see what was
not sharp in your image when playing
back at a high frame rate at 24 fps
120 frames being five times slower than
normal
now we're going to look at the power of
good framing a quick recap from film
school we've got the close-up
medium and wide shot high angle to
disempower the subject
low angle to empower the subject eye
level to speak directly to the audience
or to achieve
a neutral feel ots meaning over the
shoulder of a cast member to look at
your subject
and pov means point of view like in a
shooter game
panning refers to moving the camera left
or right horizontally and tilting
meaning to move it up or down vertically
dutch tilt means to shoot
diagonally then tracking in to add
tension
tracking out to decrease tension and
then merging a zoom with the tracking
shot you can zoom in
and track out or zoom out and track in
this achieves what's known as a
hitchcock zoom
and this is done to add an extreme
amount of teach as seen in this famous
shot
in jaws handheld refers to shooting
holding the camera in your hand and
locked off refers to locking it off on a
tripod
if you don't have a tripod here's a
quick hack with two small bags of
lentils added to her pouch
this creates great support for your
camera especially when you're doing
things like time lapses
lock it off for me there's nothing
better than the correct use of handheld
accompanied by a locked or frame
this is how i shoot most of my films
next we're going to talk about shot
listing it's super super important to
shot list before going out and actually
shooting
even if it's a small self-funded film or
phone for youtube and then obviously a
high-scale production
always shotless and if you don't know
what a shot list is this is a list where
you will describe the framing here are
the things to consider before writing
your shot list
size the size of your subject has a
direct relationship to the importance of
that subject
relationships when we see more than one
character in a shot
we are meant to acknowledge their
relationship balance
a balanced frame includes elements on
the left and the right hand side of
frame the guard of framing is the
director wes anderson
each frame is so well considered
aesthetic and balanced
based on how you plan to position your
subjects you'll need to adjust your
camera work
capture all your framing details on a
shot list well before you arrive on set
that way you have a clear idea for the
scene
and can communicate your vision with
ease that's not to say things may not
change the day of the shoot
you'll always have to be prepared to
switch things up but always consider
what you're doing and how it will
communicate to your audience
don't get caught in the trap of shooting
something a certain way just because it
looks pretty
then lastly the 180 degree room 180
degree rule sets an imaginary axis
or eye line between two characters or
between a character
and an object by keeping the camera on
one side of this imaginary access
the characters maintain the same left to
right relationship to each other
keeping the space of the scene orderly
and easy to follow
once you understand the fundamentals of
good framing you can move on to camera
movement
don't just start tracking for the sake
of it or my worst is
use your friend's stabilizer just
because he has one
like i said before in my opinion a
well-considered
locked-off shot tells a far better story
than a pointlessly
moving cinematic fluid shot
however there is something really
special about camera movement
to reduce or to add tension as well as
when you're shooting
tabletop fashion or music videos if your
friend doesn't have a stabilizer
and you really want to add movement
here's some cheap ways to do so
to rent a wheelchair from a prop house
super cheap and very effective
like i said i avoid perfection with my
cinematography so doing long track
shots like this works better for me you
can make use of a towel or
carpet too this will give you really
smooth movements
and then lastly if you want to shoot an
object rotate you can use two pieces of
wood
the one with a nail in it like this and
then just spin it
if you have the ability to use motion
control go for it as this offer won't
come around
often i've shot with these mainly for
interesting pack shots on tv commercials
when it comes to movement there are
loads of ways you can be creative
just take a look at the instagram page
shittyriggs to see how creative
filmmakers get
i love it and also if you're on
instagram go follow me there
i'll pop a link below then as promised
earlier more and my friends and
collaborators at epidemic sound you've
heard me say this 100 times and
i'll say it again when it comes to sound
and music for your videos there's
literally no way better to go than to
the epidemic sound and music live
i'm not just saying that because they
support my journey as a filmmaker but
i'm saying that because
before i found epidemic sound i would
spend days just looking for
a singular track that's that's perfect
for a video and when it comes to sound
i'll just
rip low quality sounds off of youtube
and there'll be no filing
it's just a big mess and now all i have
to do is schedule in an hour to source
all sound and music for post-production
as epidemic sound is just that
user-friendly and the library of great
tunes is just so extensive that i don't
think i've heard the same track twice
furthermore they offer these stems as
downloadable
for you to create your own unique track
progression
other than that don't forget you're
awesome brew and i'll see you next week
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah